[Musique]
nouvelle étape dans l'allègement du
protocole sanitaire lundi signé la fin
du pass vaccinale et du port du masque
pour les entreprises les commerces et
les écoles seule exception les
transports et les établissements de
santé le pôle culturel de montigny le
bretonneux a pris place au centre
aznavour depuis lundi il comprendra
notamment un auditorium de 150 places et
un studio d'enregistrement
inauguration prévue les 26 et 27 mars
prochains il vient en partenariat avec
renault et plug power a inauguré sa
première chaîne d'assemblage de
batteries à hydrogène à flins ces
batteries alimenteront les futurs
véhicules renault elles permettront aux
véhicules électriques d'avoir plus
d'autonomie le club de nationale 2 2
laisse football poissy a accueilli cinq
joueurs ukrainiens professionnelle et
leur entraîneur sur leur pelouse une
initiative du président du club lui-même
d'origine ukrainienne et la générosité
continue l'équivalent de 40 poids lourds
de dons ont été collectés par les
commune yvelinoise ils ont été
rassemblées par le département et
partiront pour l'ukraine
enfin la sixième édition de la job
academy a débuté au château de
versailles demandeurs d'emploi et
professionnels de l'établissement se
sont rencontrés ils ont travaillé en
binôme pendant trois mois la mission des
parrains accompagner leurs filleuls vers
un emploi pérenne
[Musique]